il n'est pas candidat mais il les met
tous au pas ou plutôt au pacte bay roux
buffet sarkozy royal voynet en tout dix
prétendants à l'elysée avait répondu ce
matin à l'appel de nicolas hulot ils ont
tous signé devant les caméras son pacte
écolo et pris des engagements pour
mettre l'environnement au coeur de leur
action and charline lamballe
mission accomplie pour nicolas hulot au
bas de son pacte écologique dit
signature celle de dix prétendants à
l'elysée les candidats de tous bords ont
répondu présent à son appel
quinze minutes montre en main ils se
sont pliés à l'exercice imposé évoqué à
la tribune leur engagement pour
l'écologie
l'excellence environnementale que je
veux porter n'est pas un slogan ce n'est
pas une annonce circonstancielle c'est
un engagement à agir avec détermination
et courage sous l'oeil de nicolas hulot
les candidats tentent de convaincre tous
se disent prêts à lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique à revoir les
politiques de transports de l'énergie et
de l'agriculture
même si certains affichent leur
différence il suffit pas vous demandiez
pour obtenir il suffit pas que vous
disiez pour convaincre c'est un dialogue
c'est un échange c'est un respect mutuel
vous avez vos préoccupations votre
expérience j'ai la mienne j'ai le devoir
de parler aussi à des millions de
français dernier a passé son grand oral
nicolas sarkozy n'aura croisé aucun
autre candidat la signature du pacte
écologique n'a pas prêté au débat juste
des promesses ce soir sur notre antenne
nicolas hulot voulait croire sincère
j'ai du mal à imaginer que sur un enjeu
aussi universel fondamentale qui met en
péril l'avenir de l'humanité on puisse
s'affranchir
chemin faisant d'engagement qui ont été
faits ce matin pas face à moi mais
devant les français plus candidat mais
toujours dans la bataille présidentielle
nicolas hulot réussi son tour de force
rendre l'écologie incontournable